SEC authorizes Bitcoin spot ETF in
crypto's breakthrough there's uh uh this
is uh uh Rob is this the most recent
recent story because one just came out
last night do you have the most recent
one is that the one I'm reading because
that's the one I want to read let me go
the most recent one will be up on the
screen okay then pull up the one up on
the screen so SEC approves rule change
that paved the way for Bitcoin ETF the
approval could prove uh to be a landmark
event in the adoption of cryptocurrency
by mainstream Finance the decision will
likely lead to the conversion of
grayscale Bitcoin trust which holds $29
billion of cryptocurrency into an nftd
traditional asset managers include Black
Rock and Fidelity are also poised to
launch Bitcoin funds this has two
different meanings Tom said something
before we started a podcast I don't want
to steal a thunder I want him to give
his perspective on what he thinks this
is to him because a lot of people are
sitting there saying this is big this is
this this is that Tom what does this
mean to you um congratulations Bitcoin
this is day one of your regulated life
uh that is what's happening here it
doesn't mean that all the good things
and everything about crypto and Bitcoin
are going away it just means that there
is people saying this legitimizes
Bitcoin well I would challenge that
statement and say you're right but this
also steps up where you're going to
regulate Bitcoin and what's interesting
is SEC chair Gary Gensler he clar ified
he said let me clarify this quote while
we approve the listing and trading of
spot Bitcoin ETP shares we did not
approve or endorse Bitcoin wait a minute
you did approve it it's basically like
the pimp saying I'm happy to make money
on prostitution but I don't endorse it
that's exactly
what up hes down Tom go for it that's
what he just said B they are desperately
trying not to endorse it but they are
they are also eagerly stepping forward
to start regulating it so basically what
they've said is now it can be trade so
in other words an ETF can buy some
Bitcoin and put it in there that's what
they're saying so if you bought an ETF
that was in you know speculative
currencies or something like that and
it's got a few things in there okay now
Bitcoin can be part of that basket but
this is this is day one of a different
future for Bitcoin it does legitimize it
but it also means that now the sec's can
be making the rules so I think they're
calling this a watershed moment for
Bitcoin look we see that Bitcoin is now
at 475 I think it's alltime Peak was
what in the high 60s almost 70 so
they're saying that this could be the
reason that it can Pummel it up to
$100,000 per coin we'll see what happens
there but look re regulation for the
most part can be a good thing what does
regulation do you guys know this dealing
with the insurance stuff and the annuity
stuff and the financial planning stuff
you said legitimacy no doubt it gives
trust into the marketplace and it gives
credibility So Bad actors and people who
are basically taking advantage of people
sorry you're not going to be able to
scam as many people with whatever you're
doing there's going to be some
regulation there and overregulation as I
think what people have a problem with
but laying down regulation the the law
of the land s of speak the the the the
road map to how to basically trade this
type of asset class I think overall
going to be a good thing and I think
it'll help legitimize the good actors in
The crypto space and by the way a lot of
there's a community in the crypto side
that wants that there's a community in
the Krypto sounds like dude just tell us
what the regulation is so we can you
know we can PVE it accordingly and move
forward yeah I look at regulation like
if you look at a football game you know
very nuanced game there a 50 yard line
you never heard of football all the guys
out there so there's American you know
there's American football guys and then
there's the regular what I'm saying is
tell us the rules like you know but like
in General it's like okay 10 yards is a
first down good got it right you can
kick a field goal on fourth down like
basic rules two point like R rather than
hey you 11 you 11 just run around and do
and we'll just kind of keep score
the end no there's regulation that now
when they're like over regulated it gets
to the point where it's annoying where
well you can't dance in the end zone or
if you're not if your socks aren't a
certain length that's overregulation but
regulation in sport and in finance is
actually a good thing without being too
cumbersome and burdensome on the rules
in 2008 it was a good thing that they
came back and they regulated you know
loans cuz a lot of basic American
consumers got really hurt by getting
into bad loans Nina yeah they came back
no income no asset that's right they
came back and by the way the people
pushing them into it mortgage brokers
wanted their commission but then the the
the clientele the consumer often not an
informed consumer was was taken
advantage of and ended up in debt and a
bad pinch with that so it some
regulation is good it's good that
insurance companies are regulated so
there's a a sufficient loss Reserve so
that you know if everybody covered by
State Farm Home Insurance in Alabama
when a hurricane comes through State
Farm has the money to pay and it's good
to have that regulation there where the
overregulation happens is what's
happening now in insurance is where
Elizabeth Warren says wait a minute I
don't think the salespeople should make
this kind of a commission wait wait who
the hell are you the do stuff she's
doing yeah yeah yeah who the hell are
you you know we have a good industry
here people are getting an insurance
policy it's protecting their family the
money is there when when the you know
ultimate the person passes away so it
can protect the family and S to serve
the family and you're here on the front
in trying to tell people what they
should pay their employees and turn a
commission yeah Lizzy baby you take you
and your fake you know Native American
background and get out of this get out
of the side of it that's overregulation
to to your point you leave pahas alone
okay is that the most expensive thing
for like cuz for one Bitcoin
$47,000 is that the most expensive thing
for one thing on the for for a stock
market what do you mean no no no burar
haway is like you know birkar hathway is
always hovering between $250 to
$500,000 if you want to buy one type in
what is Burk halfway
share for one share one share what is B
halfway share price A and B $553,000 for
one share right sh this is the CL this
is the a b a if you have one share of
birkshire go to go to fiveyear uh go to
fiveyear onward you are go all the way
to the right yeah there you go oh it's
CL look at it it's it's uh it's $553,000
a share right now for Brookshire hathway
they do okay you wanted to buy a share
Pat just taught me something see no I
didn't know that birkshire 500 so you
own an a if you own a certain amount of
aare or an a share you get to go to
their annual shareholder meeting that's
great which is help in Omaha and you
hear him go back and forth which will no
longer happen with the late Charlie
Monger so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here